so first I'm very curious about the
structure of the script and being able
to figure out how it's flowing while
you're writing because this is not a
traditionally formatted story here yeah
I you know I I tend to not think
linearly and so I want storytelling to
be reflective and when people tell
stories they're suddenly telling you a
story they go oh wait a minute I forgot
to tell you something two months before
this thing happened you need to know
about these things etc and so for a
movie that's basically about making
assumptions about people but without
taking any opportunity to get to know
them or making assumptions that you know
what's going on I think that the movie
was structured in a very specific way to
be in a in a perspective a point of view
unfortunately that point of view is
often shot and killed or explodes and
then you have to sort of switch but the
idea of getting almost an hour into the
movie before you start to explain what
the villains are really up to and why
that's the way it is my favorite kind of
story to tell because people don't give
you their motivation in life nobody
likes to really explain why they're
behaving the way that they are and very
few people even know why they're
behaving the way they are how was a role
pitch to someone like like Emma Roberts
do you actually go up to her and say you
know we want you in this movie but we're
gonna kill you off in a flash well it's
a great question that's what Jason Blum
is for Jason makes that call he has a
relationship with Emma and I think that
part of the fun of the role was
essentially we need somebody who the
audience is actually gonna believe is
gonna be the star of a Jason Blum movie
that would be you and just know that
you're gonna get killed about five
minutes in and Emma was like that sounds
delightful
I don't know if she use the word
delightful she my in my in my
recollection she did but she was just
she was totally gay I often describe
most of the bloody horror movies I see
as delightful so I understand something
about this another very untraditional
thing about this movie is that Betty
your character is like I guess she's
pretty much the same from start to
finish she's very consistent so I'm just
curious what is it like playing a
character with an untraditional arc like
that yeah well to me she has a an
internal arc but I do think that it's
rare to see a female protagonist who
you're not let in on every step that's
going on in her brain I'm used to as an
actress playing of characters who really
externalize what they're thinking and
feeling and wanting and needing and it
was really fun to get to play someone
who is not letting you in on their
secret you know it's when Craig was
talking to me about casting in this way
he was saying I was saying you know I'm
a TV person they're not going to let me
be the star of this movie and he's like
no we're gonna cast it with a bunch of
movie stars who just died at the
beginning we'll just put all them in the
trailer just wait I mean if glow hasn't
already done it your performance in this
I'm not just saying it's I'm sitting
here and it's something else one of my
favorite scenes in the movie is your
conversation with sergeant Dale and in
particular the moment where she doesn't
actually verbalize with words what she's
trying to say I'm curious was that in
the script or is that something that you
came up with that was not on the page
and you know in watching those dailies I
was like man I like cuz now I'm gonna
have to tell everybody that that wasn't
my idea it was so good like words always
get in the way of moments like that and
obviously you have to have an incredible
performance to be able to communicate
something non-verbally like that
particularly in that moment and in the
context of a fun ridiculous over-the-top
movie to suddenly just say bring it in
everybody
let's just get real every time I've seen
the movie play the audience just gets
super quiet and then when Betty makes
that move there's sort of like a little
bit of uncomfortable laughter but it
just feels like it's it's exactly what
the screenplay needed and didn't have so
thank you for identifying that and for
prescribing it and for administering it
well it's really rare you know I love
being an actor but I also love
appetizers and paying my rent and I you
know a lot of roles I've played it feels
a little like maybe it feels like this
in any job where sometimes it feels like
soul church and sometimes it feels like
you're putting lip gloss on your journey
and selling it for five cents and the
rolls like this script it just felt like
every door in my brain creatively was
open because of the writing because of
Craig's direction and it just felt like
one of those rare times where you feel
just sort of unplugged and there's a
clear highway from your deepest weirdest
ideas out of your brain and you can't do
that alone it has to be in really good
writing and with really good direction
and yeah can I just say this not to be
super serious but between 4 p.m. and 6
p.m. if you go to Applebee's there's
free appetizers ok you can get jalapeno
poppers like all that stuff and you
deserve right you deserve appetizers you
also deserve all the grilled cheese in
the world
the fact that there's not a full spread
of grilled cheese I'm like disappointed
there's any variation in hospitality
today Universal who's been amazing in
every way that I can imagine but they
won't spring for the gray air like they
just won't do it
I'm an American cheese I don't know if
it was a drop career no I think it was
career was American cheese or mozzarella
cheese I love Hilary putting in her
contract I yes
she's all about those those the cheese
choices right what she does right after
the events of the movie like does she
fly home and kind of get I don't know
like a renewed sense of confidence and
go about her life in a different way
yeah Craig and I were joking but maybe
she just doesn't tell anyone and the
sequel is just her in a rom-com and she
like keeps trying to be like so this
crazy thing happened he was like I'm
gonna actually keep talking and then you
just see here like have a PTSD flashback
of it oh can you please do that there's
so many single ideas I won't get into
that with you but I do have to read one
note from the Collider team for you I'm
just going to read it in the team's work
because I don't want to take all this
I'm I should say how much money would we
need to pay you to make a watchman
season 2 oh my god I wish that
I had an idea for Watchmen season 2 and
I and I really wish that there is going
to be a watchman season 2 I just we put
it all on the field for season 1 and
every great idea we had I was like what
if we just put that in season 1 versus
oh let's let's let's stick it away for
later and so it could there be a second
season of watchman I personally hope
that there is but I but I don't think it
should exist just because people like
the first season just because I'm
curious about classifications that says
like about 370 thousand dollars is the s
very specific what was the impetus
behind changing the designation of the
show from a Drama Series to a limited
series um that that decision actually
happened well above my paygrade I think
that when we went and pitched the show
to HBO we said we're just gonna do one
season and then see where we are and
just so you know it's more of a Fargo
model or a true detective model where if
there were other seasons of the show it
would reset it's not the continuing
Adventures of these characters and they
were like cool cool cool and then when
the when the series ended they were like
are you gonna do a second season and I
was like I don't have any ideas and they
were like oh so you meant what you said
before and so I think that because
there's only going to be one of them it
feels more appropriate to call it a
limited series than a drama series but
again I don't I get consulted on these
decisions but I don't make them